in the military when you get out of the
military sometimes the challenge with
vets is
they get out they've been conditioned to
be government employees and when they
get out they've learned work ethic
they've learned to work together as a
team they've learned all this stuff but
they're small thinkers so they get a job
at the ups after they come out of the
military i made it hey i get those
additional 10 points on the test i take
hey i go become a cop hey i'll go become
a firefighter i'll go become this i've
made it and that's it and that's all i
do no problem
but you learned the most difficult thing
to be able to compete in marketplaces
which is working hard working as a team
in leadership that on free enterprise
can help you do a lot so the challenge
becomes hispanics are willing to do
those jobs you got to think a little bit
bigger and the hispanic voices like
yourself like the ramoses like those
people out there have to say hey why
don't you go compete with musk
instead of saying poor you you can't
compete with musk